January 20th the day the devil was
buried at Sea they burned his nut sack
and they made him [__] drink cumcum
juice that's the come after the come you
[__] put in the freezer and you save
it you ice cube it you make the [__]
eat it in the corner with handcuff you
me they made those you you put a [__]
in the corner with handcuffs and you WIP
off in the ice tray and you put it in
the [__] freezer for a couple hours
and it gets all [__] up and then
you you never did that what what you
people grow up what's happening You
Beautiful [__] the Church of
What's Happening Now mck BC court guest
of the [__] evening this evening Lis
at the Flying Jew what up you bad
[__] in the red shirt was that
oh my God I I couldn't sleep last night
you got [__] up that star of death was
on fire last night D yeah it was I ate
three of those [__] I have no
idea how you did I had a candy and then
I went home and started smoking hash out
of a [__] pipe by 8:00 I think by
7:30 my head was [__] spinning right
I I was falling asleep on a on a chair
so my wife put a pillow and a blanket on
top of me and the baby came over and
ripped the blanket off and ripped the
pillow off like wake up you [__] no
sleep in the living room seriously today
she HD my keys I couldn't go to
Jiu-Jitsu today my car keys were missing
I couldn't [__] find them my wife
figured out that your keys are like he
always leaves with these my wife found
them in the [__] Grill under the oven
no God I had no car till [__] 3:00 I
walked to the park and I walked with 235
lb k Bells like a jerk B to the park I'm
going to be sore as [__] tomorrow
hammies on fire she hid the [__] keys
on me today so yeah you know it was one
of those days what's up with you baby
boy well you I was up at 6:00 a.m. oh I
was [__] up and he you called me and
you tried to convince me to go to Denny
to get milkshakes at 6 a.m. [__] yeah
it's 5:30 you been to bed yet or no yeah
I slept like a Sabbath that's the least
of your problems on these Edibles you
sleep like a [__] something
about him yesterday that woke me up
though at 3:00 a.m. I was still high as
[__] you know it's called hunger that's
what woke you up told me yourself you
woke up and ate 19 [__] wheat waffles
four waffles yeah four waffles four full
siiz waffles no the
Egos and with sugarless [__] maple
syr sugar free syr I told him to cut my
eyeballs at 3: in the morning he was
drinking it like a [__] thing of
water spring water he was drinking that
maple syrup look at you I called him up
I'm like come on I'll take you it D he's
picked me up let's go get a milkshake
and a grand slam well you didn't with
that what were we going to do first
we're going to smoke a [__] hash
joint smoke some
Reef go to Denny's [__] soba the only
way to go no one goes they charge you
double yeah you don't go to Denny's soba
that's for [__] Gentiles you go to
Denny's you go [__] up so you don't
remember but the the other [__] up
thing about you Joe is like I would have
gotten ready a year or two ago and like
been in my car and he would have called
me be like don't worry about it dog to
Den's you don't want to go to Denny's I
end up eating cheros with skim like a
[__] half a
f baby that you put anything on the
Cheerios or no really just dry not even
a little sprinkles SK whatever that [__]
is nah n you can't put that I eat sugar
in the morning the rest of the day I
want [__] popcorn and lollipops and
[__] yeah I got to watch that's the
first thing to go if you [__] around
with breakfast sugar in the morning
you're [__] so you could eat sugar
like a two or something just to give you
a little boost and a protein shake I'll
put a little sugar on a protein shake
really why not like you're supposed to
little salt little [__] wow you
season your protein shakes you got to
dope them up some clamps you know what
I'm saying you got to dope you got to
dope everything up you can't eat it like
that out of a can you know Progresso is
not a bad clam CH you got to dope it up
Campbell not a bad clam CH you got to
dope it up I think that's your favorite
thing even back to mad flavors world you
were doping up steaks he took me to
7-Eleven and Tommy how to dop up their
Italian sub sure you have what you put
on there listen you take that Italian
sub that looks [__] one thing about
Subway that this [__] guy and nobody
believes me is that all their Coke Cuts
all their Coke cuts are made from Turkey
turkey products so when you get the
pastrami you're really eating the
[__] turkeyy liver it's like yeah
it's gel it's gelled and it looks like
pastrami so but 7-Eleven go in there and
get the Italian early in the morning you
take that Italian you take it home you
take that [__] terrorist lettuce they
put on it and that tomato that that's
you take it off and you put the oven on
BR and you put that oven on you put that
sandwich in the top you take it out you
put fresh lettuce vinegar and oil salt
and pepper a little oregano and a
[__] crushed red
what you got yourself a tremendous
Italian sandwich and it's not bad I did
it one time about a year and a half ago
cuz somebody told me on the East Coast
they go bro you go to 7 lemonade I'm
like come on they go not the hot dogs
and ship if you're in a bind I was doing
a play and I was in a bind one day I
said let me see if it's true I got the
chicken salad on wheat bread I didn't
[__] blood you know I didn't get purple
get sick I mean if you get egg salad you
deserve to be shot forget it yeah you
know if you get egg salad yeah Sushi 101
you're going to be [__] you're going
to end up in a
I know this [__] guy got Sushi from S
no I did not from there's a sushi place
by where I live on Laurel Canyon I went
there one called
712 yeah and he got sick at his house he
wants to blame on the edible you know
the brownies you gave your your family
no no no I gave him different ones he
gave he took home a reat he took home
atie Dolores stuff I gave him anti same
strength No I gave you Kryptonite the
devil's wrath yeah I gave and he gave it
he gave me a full one and and I had
never had him before I went home and had
sushi and I was on the couch for like 3
hours and I finally made it to the
bedroom but I flipped over and I felt I
felt nauseous I puked on my bed no right
next to it like I I I took all my
concentration not to puke on the bed I
puked right next to it but I couldn't
even make it to the bathroom you said de
the [__] edible he's made me puke
three times 7-Eleven sush no it wasn't 7
listen smoked a joint then I drank a
gallon of gasoline and that [__]
joint made me sick this guy will go into
those MC Nation joints where they're
Korean but they're really making sushi
no he don't know I I won't get sushi at
Korean place yes you do I know I I got I
went to a Korean place to get dumplings
and you got mad no
I what's wrong with dumplings everyone
makes D want go to war against them with
the [__] movie and you're going to a
Korean place this what I'm talking about
he don't think with his [__] head uh
he'll go to like a Japanese place and
get like Korean food he does everything
backwards he's going to get sick one of
these days and he eats hummus and [__]
out these terrorist place these Baba Gan
and all that [__] wait till he's [__] in
blood I can't wait till he calls me up
from the hospital one day my liver blew
up for me the seafood's the [__] you got
to work worry about completely man
especially from 7 when I was driving
trucks back in Chicago my breakfast in
the morning was two chili cheese dogs a
large bag of Doritos and one of those
triple gulps whatever the biggest gulp
was full of Mountain Dew with two pack
of Marboro Reds like a just a [__]
caveman champ just like cuz when you
smokeing Marboro Reds s in the morning
yeah in between chili dogs Doritos and
Mountain Dew and I'm coming in at a
sweet sexy 242 I'm in a box truck so all
the Smoke's just there's no filtration
of the smoke just W tremendous
everything smells even your nut go
[__] jeans showing up to someone's
house hey I got to bring this inside
when I used to work what's that club on
on the South Side the one that I used to
riddles when I used to work riddles they
used to put me in a hotel that there was
one of those Japan vills next to it like
sushi sanm like what's oh like a Benny
like a Benny Han and they had sushi and
I would go over there why is it called
Japan bille because there's one Asian
restaurant yeah it was like Japan Ville
it was just a little thing and it wasn't
bad but I always get the white tuna and
I get sick than the dog really and the
guy would say to me I don't feel good he
goes what'd you eat I go I went to that
sushi place I had the the chicken
teriyaki but I had a couple rows of sush
she's like let me ask you something show
me the ocean why are you eating that
[__] I thought about him well he's right
why saw white fish out of the lake the
[__] yeah it's white fish out of the
lake that [__] in Arizona and Tempe at
The Improv everybody used to get sick
upstairs yeah the you could eat sushi
everybody got sick never get sushi
everybody got [__] sick eating that
[__] you get sick on Sushi it's one of
the worst six you will ever be and you
were lucky you just ate that bad [__]
like a day old wasn't after a while like
they had in the back next to the dogs
and [__] you know what I'm saying they
got confused remember they gave you a
piece of dog and told you it was
eel I don't get eel I got tuna same
difference I mean you don't know you
don't know what the [__] you're eating
when you go to a sushi place unless
you're a fisherman you don't [__]
know what you're eating at a sushi place
all right you order and they tell you
whatever they can tell you whatever you
know it's an imitation crab meat rolled
up in the California rooll they cut it
and they put mayo in them out here it's
gross East Coast it's just crab they put
mayo in it they make like a crab salad
it's disgusting yeah I think it's the
same thing with wine too when people are
like oh you can taste the tannins and
the hint of Oak it's [__] I hear the
best wine is Trader Joe's $2 wine yeah
Two Buck Chuck man get get get down on
it that whole wine thing it's [__]
drives
me crazy since I was a kid you mean you
you don't have a favorite uh
seleo not p no guy I hate people get the
glasses I think I the glass is for
everything yeah when I was a kid I used
to go to this guy's house he was a great
kid I loved him with all my hand I still
talk to
him but whenever girls came over he'd
always ask him do you want wine and and
I would sit there and I'd be seething
like just give him the [__] bug Wiis
let's go what theck we're all going for
the same result here 4:00 a.m. you rip
the box of frania open you get the
silver aluminum foil and you squeeze the
wine out he used to get come down with
the wine glasses I wanted to break them
over his f [__] head like when I see
somebody drinking wine out of a wine
glass I really want to break it over
their head not in the restaurant you you
got to do what you you do the pinky up
that whole thing drives me you don't
have like a whiskey glass at home no do
the thing you you got to look at the
waiter nod to him like this is okay it's
all such a shitty dog and pony show when
I was a waiter they would have people
come in and teach classes so we would
sound like we knew what we were talking
about but we'd always just pick like a
medium priced one not to pick the most
expensive one and not the cheapest one
and just say that was the best and tag
an extra fin on it market price next to
it it out these [__] don't know
nothing today you know your menu you
just tell I want them to use his menu
just keep [__] working you put like a
market on like a deck of cards and then
there you put market price on the wines
you just go to like a 445 while you're
eating and that's your manually say you
make four of them ready just in case you
get a table of four little MP I miss
being a server sometimes you do what do
you miss about it was great money
especially I was in I made I went home
one Christmas break uh and I worked and
I made two grand in like a week and a
half and I was like 20 21 I worked at
Legal Seafoods I don't know if you've
been back to Boston it's like a not a
not a cheap seafood place but not like
$200 a plate either so like a kick up
from Red Lobster a couple kick couple
kicks up it was pretty good it's pretty
good it's East Coast I wasn't there no
but Itor CLS on a half shell muscles but
I hate Lobster and I would always say
whenever anyone would come in what
should I get Lobster cuz it's [__]
expensive hate Lobster I I haven't tried
it in years maybe if I tried it again
I'd like it how did you eat it they
always just steam it with butter that's
all you like you like [__] butter I
mean butter [__] drawn butter no I've
I've done it and what about Lobster
those new things they got in those
trucks the lobster sandwi lobster rolls
oh delicious toasted bread out a nice
roll 13 bucks for like [__] 2 oz you
get it cold or hot cuz they think you
can get hot Lobster I like them both
mayonnaise I like them nice little
[__] celery in nice little lobster
roll yeah [__] tremendous on that
little Ro there's one guy the Lobster
Truck I think it's called there's a
lobster truck right there that from
Boston then there's another one that I
had the Cajun food oh that guy and he
stands out take a sample take a sample
that guy [__] I just got the black beans
and rice the red beans and rice there's
one that you'd hate and it's disgusting
which one Sushi burritos they make a
burrito size sushi sushi roll it's
disgusting what it's called like jashi
or something joaki some of this [__] is
not necessary why would you do that it's
gross it's like a trunin I got to put a
turkey in a dunan and a [__] turkey
and a Dun dck I can never figure that
out that's like my rub is cuute duck I
sit there at 2: in the morning go who
the [__] would shove a dunk a duck up a
[__] turkey's ass and now they're
really going crazy they're shoving
snakes inside a duck inside a dog inside
a turkey inside a
[__] you you when I told you that I
uh that my girlfriend got a dog you said
I should have her just take the dog to
like Panda Express for 10 bucks it's a
little every time I would bring it up
like when is you going to take that dog
to Panda Express trade it in for number
four on a Thursday they'll give you
[__] eight nine bucks for a [__]
dog right there at hoy's walk you can
bring them to the back just bang on the
door and time around thing guy put pop
the tires of the delivery truck truck
didn't make it this week I robbed a
Chinese delivery guy once like in
1985 we were hanging out at 88 Street
Park and some guy pulls over excuse me
oh no do you know where why would he do
that mistake number one do you know
where whatever is like what yeah down
the corner and we made him stop and when
he was looking it was one of those
places where he had to walk in and look
deep and like 13 me and we got in this
car and we started [__] delivering
some of the Chinese food that's where it
got [__] crazy but you made his runs
we delivered like three stops we took
the rest of the Chinese food and ate it
and just let left the car parked on like
64th Street field why would he deliver
the food cops
$150 all they paid in cash when you're
[__] 18 you know $150 $150 you just
like 10 grand no they didn't pay in cash
we told them to pay cash and what did
you do with the car we dropped it
off we knew everybody in North b a
horrible mistake horrible M walking up
into with dark park like four guys on
the bench going hey guys anybody got
changed for 100 like what are you doing
like there's a there's a register in the
park in the middle there's a guy with
chains what are you doing he's in the
alley go follow weren you a Chinese
delivery guy for a while I was a Chinese
delivery guy in bould of Colorado I
worked at that restaurant in bould there
a Chinese place there were
Vietnamese they were Vietnamese they
pissed me off when I found out they lied
to me the whole time I was a custom for
three years and at that time I was
already in but it was when I was really
[__] like in bad shape I had the
apartment I was divorced and they would
deliver Wednesday I would get the the
kid I would get my daughter and they
deliver the Chinese food and one day
they showed up I looked at the guy and I
go hey
man I had the money he goes just come by
later talk to us that's how cool he was
you know how embarrassed I
was and uh he goes listen man you've
been eating with us for years anytime
you want to order put it on the tab wow
and uh and then I [__] It was 95 to
be exact the year that the Houston
Rockets won the series they were
gambling [__] these China men
these Vietnamese were gambling whole
family no I went in there one day and
they're like hey we part of the pool you
in the pool you got you hit the number I
won and they were like laughing at me we
got this guy you got houon rocket you
got Houston Rocket the king to the dream
and I kept going in there they kept
winning and winning and winning no [__]
and finally they won I think I won 500
bucks I but the I used to deliver
Chinese food and sell Coke so that was
my cover I used to work for a sports
betting service from August to February
1st once February 1st came you
unemployed it was [__] pulling teeth
you go no one's baseball he would bet he
would pay you 6 700 but you just made
calls for8 hours a day the people oh you
had to hustle the phones they just
basketball and hockey and after football
it's pro basketball and baseball hasn't
started March is good because of March
Madness March you still have a little
bit of life but once I mean once
football tape is off it's 50% of your
business yeah so if you were making
10,000 a week you're going to make five
now and it's basketball so you have a
good March once College basketball's
over you got baseball and pro basketball
that takes you till June but those
summer mons he would pay 300 a week
you'd say come in it's 1 to three in the
summer like 1 to 4 1 to 5 Wednesdays and
Thursdays off or something Tuesdays and
Wednesdays off but in the winter you
work six days a week and you had
Wednesdays off I had do my everything on
Wednesday you have no idea what life you
know how it is out here but dog in the
in the off season you were supposed to
put money away and then they would send
you checks like the guy had it down he
had the business down he didn't want
none of his people out there starving so
he go look and during the year you're
making 10 grand a week put two away so
in June you got money he would you put
it in the trust account that he get the
and [__] and they mail you the money
every week I didn't do
that I [__] I'll take I took it now I
took the big lump something sarted it I
had this dealer his name was Vince
Wilson I loved him with all my heart he
would delivered to me you know those
guys that you owe like I would call them
and he go you got my money yeah come on
he get there and he go let me see how
much you got Vince I no no no you told
me you told me dog what I you 1,400 I
had him up to like 2,200 at one time and
he would still give it to me on a Friday
night I if I gave him like a hundred
bucks were you getting a ball I was
getting a ball every time I seen him
every time wow and what was what would
you say it's 95 so what was that about
175 I saw my uh La drug dealer Friday
night at The Comedy Store no [__] well
the B there was there's a manager at The
Comedy Store as a Coke faint and I
introduced him to him and I go into
there and I give the manager a hug he
goes your buddy's on his way here I go
who he goes your buddy d man I go come
on and soon the game huh still in the
[__] game seven years later wow
that's a long run man if you're selling
he's a professional he's a
professional I know somebody who lives
on his block okay I know somebody who's
lived on his block Einstein oh wow still
on the same spot still in the same spot
how many people you think think about it
tried to [__] Jack he's been at that
place for 10 years no [__] it's a bad
mistake if you try to Jack that what I'm
saying that boy if you go to that boy's
house you're going to get a cold awake
what does he have just a ton of guns you
know what I mean never Bad to the Bone
and bigger than he's ever been he would
have been playing pro football now they
got they shot him in the legs twice yeah
you're messing with the wrong guy how I
became friends with that whole group of
them was I used to deal with this dude
White Lightning he was Jewish he thought
he was a gangster he ran Reggae night at
one of those clubs on Melrose and he
thought he was like a Jewish gangster
like a Jew star with diamonds and he had
a black girlfriend but she was sucking
everybody's dick he was just a rich
white K he didn't [__] know he used
to have weed in the building Ask Josh
Wolf about this he used to live in the
building but he was he sold big amounts
of weed but he was too scared to sell it
like he always got robbed and he would
hide it in the garage I wonder who did
that he would hide in the garage and he
would hide it this story was but I
always robbed him yeah oh I oh I always
got this [__] guy and he used to hide
it in this chick's apartment that had no
Chin you ever see those women just and
there something she got operation just
had no Chin but she had the biggest tits
and she sucked the best dick in North
America when you gave her three lines of
blow so you go over there let her suck
your dick and she was lonely she'd say
you want to smoke weed and then after
she'd smoked weed you you'd say this
weed is great she' go don't say nothing
but this is Blah Blah Blah's weed and
you go she go I got three lbs in the
back no really can you wait here I'm
going to go take a shower okay I robed
that [__] blind while she was taking a
shower get the [__] out of here what
would happen when like when your eyes
like like when someone when you saw
someone you could take with like your
eyes just go oh my God this is like7 98
and we kept robbing that [__] La when
I moved here and you hear the game out
here you're like what you can't your
head can't get around when someone's
like I'm I'm a drug dealer and they'd
say it out loud to you and you known
them for five minutes you're like you're
not a [__] drug dealer there's not a
drug dealer on the planet that I know
that would tell someone in the first 5
minutes of meeting him that they're a
[__] dealer it's just you're just
begging to get arrested or crewed up on
it's crazy you know I used to my prey
was drug dealers
from 81 to like
85 I mean I went to prison for
kidnapping the New York I went to prison
in in uh Boulder but my main pray was
drug dealers and it would we'd be cool
and then once they tell me I can't front
you if they did anything I didn't like
that was it if Lee came to me and said I
went to Mick the other night he wouldn't
front me a [__] ounce of coke at 2:
in the morning that's it we're going to
rob him and I would just work you I
would just work you work you work you
where you doing I'm going to the city
boom that means I got two hours in your
apartment yeah you're gone to the thing
unless you're taking the [__] that
was my prey for years and I got to tell
you something today I still don't feel
guilty about it like I feel guilty about
the people I Rob the drug dealers you
know I met people let me tell you what
the best thing that happened to La was
that by the time I got to La I didn't
want to do nothing else like I was
already a comedian like the comedy had
won the comedy had won but there was a
time in my life where I'd be broke at
9:00 in the morning and by 11: God would
put somebody in my life to rub and the
guy would walk up to me like I had
people come you know these are guys that
come up to me and go man I got $3,000
I'm looking to buy an ounce and a half
of coke what where's the money in my
house okay I got a guy I would [__]
work it and if you push a little bit you
know what the guy's going to be cautious
like I would push give me the money I'll
go get it oh no I got to go with you now
you're [__] Le but there were guys that
would say I'll give you the money really
all right I'll come back in an
hour Pam and what if you ever saw them
again you wouldn't see them you wouldn't
see them because right by the time I
took mix
5000 I let's say the flight to [__]
Albuquerque was at
I'd meet Mi at three so I went right
from Mick's house to the airport with
mix's money and I'd fly to like a small
destination and i' chill for three weeks
and live like a doctor get my dick sucks
smoke weeds smoke Coke really did you
have a connect in the spot you were
flying to yeah and by the time I got
back my friends would cool it and then
he would show up the guy and I go you're
not going to believe what happened we
got [__] robbed the cops were there
the FED showed they wanted your name I
want my money they wanted your name [__]
[__] you you're going to ask me for
[__] money you [__] I hit you
with this [__] no no we were just
kidding all right we lost the 5,000 it
was [__]
amazingly would you have the plane
ticket already or would you just go to
the airport I had the I had not a dime
in my pocket until I got his five
grand so you just go to the airport and
be like when's the soonest flight to us
no did you not know I already had it
planned out if the flight was at 4:55
what time I I got to be there 355 I
would meet him in in Hollywood at
[__] 3 and you would be driving I'd
be packed the luggage would be in your
car when he gave me money I was going
straight to the [__] airport Le there
was no stop there was no I got to get
flly nothing the airport yeah I give I
give a guy like you 400 you say
something I'll kill you okay I'll break
your [__] head you don't know nothing
you don't know nothing I'm going to give
you 400 and I'm going to keep in touch
with you I'm gonna call you every
[__] day I want you at that bar and
every time he comes in I want you to
[__] tell me what he says and that's
it and this guy would be at the bar and
what happened they [__] arrested me
they took me to some jail I couldn't
even tell them show me the paperwork
what [__] paper I don't want to show
you [__]
[__] or you grease the guy that
you know he's going to talk to and say I
don't know the the cops came in yeah you
looking they look for you saying Joey
got busted yeah you tell him bro he
called my mother's house I didn't even
talk to he called my mother's house you
know I had we had it down pth you were
gone it was gone how often would you do
this every two
weeks every 10 days every time a pigeon
came along I took a guy in Boulder that
wanted to join the mafia I got him for
like $3,000 he came to me one day Mick
who comes to you you're sitting there
scratching your head going man I could
use a th000 bucks and all a sudden this
kid come up I got to tell you something
I always want to be in the
mafia you know anybody in Brooklyn I'm
like I know a couple people I don't know
anybody in Brooklyn all right I don't
know anybody this is 1991 last time I
talk to somebody in Brooklyn was 83 this
you know anybody in Brooklyn I don't lot
to be what do you want to do I'm going
to join them up let me make and I would
work him I wouldn't go right for the
money I'd say let me call a guy I know
you got money it's going to cost you
like there a membership fee yeah there's
a membership fee I'm going to call you
and the guy would look at me and go are
you serious put your money away I'm not
even going to ask you what you got I'd
worked a guy that was the other thing
it's like a long con it was yeah you
have to do long cons it's a you're not
going to meet a drug dealer he's going
to let you in you're going to introduce
me to you're going to yeah a real guy is
not going to say I'm going to [__]
it's a square for sure this a month so
I'm working people monthly I got three
guys working at once how do you keep all
the stories straight I'm just waiting
for the opening you tell all three of
them the same story oh so I got you you
keep coming getting me some good Coke
we're at a bar one n you go Coco here
like oh [__] that shit's good where'd
you get that H some white guy I know up
in the studio city okay the next night
you come back look what he got he's got
rocks he's got powder now I start
working you I buy a gram two grams an a
ball an ounce I take you out of your
comence Zone you've been buying grbs
even he's going to go where you getting
this money my friend coko bro he loves
this [__] in fact he wants to buy 4 oz
that's how I get him you be the
middleman go to him and get the 4 oz but
I want to meet him 4 oz deal with go is
planned sweet and his [__] Mick Loves
Coco Mick Loves Coco you're out of the
picture you're gone I'll give you a
taste I'm not going to rob you but I
don't need you no more I'm going to deal
with directly with him and I would work
him for a month if I told him Mick let
me get 4 ounces of coke I'll be back at
9: I'd be there at 8:45 with his money
and a milkshake from [__]
Carell I let the guy rest and then one
night without even thinking dog let me
get four ANS and while I was there my
pag would go off I'd already thought you
would already see me soon as I get in
there make my pag go
off oh [__] can your phone yeah yeah and
you just be telling me about the weather
yeah it's son okay
mck [__] how we going to do
this this like I just got another call
for a guy he wants a half a pound you
got that on you yeah but I'm going any
cash you got more money than God what
does he want to pay what do you want uh
I want 14 I told him 18 we're both going
to SP let's split the money now I got
him I'm in his greed now all right let
me do this let me drop this four off and
I'll come back and pick up the eight
what's he gonna say it's Saturday night
he's getting his dick suck no no no no
no no don't come back I'll give you the
eight and the four go and come back
later on I'll meet you later at my
mother's at
two he just I just caught him at his
weakest moment because I played him I've
been playing him for a month I've been
giving him his money
now in front of him my pager goes off he
knows I'm doubling up he knows I'm
selling a quarter pound of coke a day
now I just got to call for three of them
you know what Mick here's the money for
the quarter pound let me here's money
for 2 ounces let me get six on the cuff
I still got him for six that's $122,000
plus the that's that's that's without
even me making a profit he's looking for
12 I'm going to make [__] 22 I'm
going to go make 10 cuz I'm selling it
for wholesale I don't give you got to
flip it in about 2 hours I don't give a
[__] I don't really give a [__] cuz it's
not mine how isy to sell
Coke if I call you and say I got 2
ounces of coke at 18 per that's 3600 but
tonight tonight alone from 8 to 10 Uncle
Joe is doing a sale for two grand flat
I'll move that in 15 [__] minutes wow
because it's it's 56 G it's all profit
for you it's all profit for me I don't
give a [__] it's like when I when you
come to me with a sto I got a stolen
credit card I come to you and they go
yeah what do you want the iMac yeah how
much is it 1,900 I'm going to come to
your house at 8:00 I want $1,000 for the
iMac you're not going to get that
nowhere else it's 1,800 plus tax plus
the 250 from Apple for the STA fee but
$1,000 you're going to give me and
you'll get it right you'll get it that's
a deal you're not going to get that on
Amazon I'll wait till Black Friday
you're not going to get that money I
just gave you a deal below [__] way
below cost could you sell it in like
let's say you went to a place a new town
could you find people to sell it to or
it was only like your friends I could
sell it to my friends but that's who I
where I made the move I dumped the coke
on the way out of
town I dumped I would let's say you're
the buyer you sold it before you got it
right I sold it before I got it I'm
never going to get stuck with it you I
already have your cash yeah I already
told you I'm coming over with 6 ounces
at 2,000 an ounce that's 12,000 but
you're going to give me [__] 7500
cash tonight and I'm going to give you
clean cocaine no cut no no not going to
make your nose peel nothing all right
you're [__] you're going to cut that
and you're going to sell that I'm moving
that right out of town when I even when
I was a regular drug dealer and I played
Danny B you know Danny B who calls you I
used to get drugs from him I get a quar
let's say I get a quarter kilo from him
that's 10 ounces right let's say 10 and
1 12 ounces I get 10 and 1 12 ounces for
those days for 6,500 bucks all right my
goal was to make a profit because I'm a
Coke feiend so I would make sure before
I got on that plane to pick it up I
already had $10,000 worth of cash sold
so when I got off the plane I already
had $3,500 worth of profit I'm picking
up 6 ounces but I'm selling three right
off the bat I'm selling four right off
the bat at 18 a grand or whatever you
you follow them you see how this if I'm
a coke dealer I don't want to buy a kilo
to put kilo in my house I want to do
that I'm buying a kilo you don't want
you don't want to figure it out I don't
want to figure it out you don't want to
have a kilo of cocaine and you got to
figure it out when I go to mix's house
I'm going with 5 ounces of cut in the
bag he's going to give me the Coke I'm
going to open it I'm going to throw my
cut I'm going to take an ounz of pure in
I'm going to throw four in I'm going to
shake it up real good and crunch it up
and bring that to your house I'm going
to do the cut right on the way to your
house this is no laboratory this ain't
no naked girls with baggies this is
Uncle Joe he Rock and [__] roll and a
real guy guy never would have let you
bring in another guy would say that's on
you if you want to move weight you move
it I'll give it to you and that's on you
I don't want to meet a new guy but some
people go no let me meet him yeah the
real greet like people wants to meet you
man that don't have a tight [__] game
those are the that's why I surprised
that guy's been in the same spot for 10
years cuz most guys 6 months nine months
or they're renting three different spots
so when you go see them it's a stash
spot anyway it's not even where he lives
well this is where he lives but I know
he's got a stash spot he's got a stash
spot around town but he does all his
business this very when he comes back
from getting the product he calls you
this is the way he worked with me he was
very smart he called me and he would say
this is what I got he knew what I had
sometimes he'd give me a big chunk
sometimes but he would leave right town
again he's been selling for 20 years in
this area so he's got his customers he
takes no Outsiders yeah that's the key
takes no Outsiders I know a guy in
Jersey I grew up with I'm 51 he's 51
bought a house he has a
Chevy he works parttime I know he's got
a half a m put away for sure and a
speaker I know for a fact he's been
selling blows since high school this guy
he lives you know modestly he doesn't go
out to dinners if he moves 2 ounces a
weekly makes
$45,000 it's 20,000 a month and nobody
knows what you're doing that's 240 a
year nobody knows what you're doing cash
because the people you're dealing with
with are very these people are fiends
when I was snorting coke I was a fiend
Let's Pretend if I was doing this type
of cocaine when I was on a TV show right
two years I got one guy I'm dealing with
in two years you're going to make a
fortune off me you're going to take it
all that guy's taking everything yeah
he's taking everything it's it's the
drug dealer world is amazing but super
drug dealers and there smart drug
dealers you don't even want nothing in
your house especially a guy like me if I
got an ounce of coke before I got to my
house there' only be two grams left so
the worst that get in trouble is with
those two GRS does it even upset drug
dealers when they get arrested or is it
just part of no no they're very happy
well no not being happy but yeah they're
[__] upset they just I didn't know I
didn't know if it was just like part of
doing business like well it's it's it
depends what type of drug dealer you are
if you're making 20 move 20 key moves a
week or a month and you're [__] you
know making a half a mill a [__]
month eventually somebody's going to
[__] crack you know you know that as
a smart businessman you're going in and
going wow I've already done this for a
year I've got uh 200,000 under my
mattress yeah you know do I stop get out
point do I stop or do I keep going you
know that's what you were talking about
the greedy guys I had there was a guy
the first comic in Chicago not the first
but at least in my generation that hit
that got a uh he got a talent holding
deal out of the Chicago Comedy Festival
in 2000 and we didn't even know there
was such a thing we didn't even know
what that meant they gave him 20
50,000 I think I was
26 and he might have been 24 like that
was like stock broker money like no one
made that money in in our the circles we
were traveling that was bizarre
money five months later he moved the
dealer into his house that's how that's
how Sly that dealer was he got next to
him right away he found out about the
money he started fronting him he got him
charged up he started feeding the ego
getting the guy high on himself and then
he said listen man why do I got to go
home why don't I [__] come in here
and the party never ends like you make
sense how fast did let 250 go gone it
was gone in here where is he now Florida
I think that kid who to Florida comedy
still yeah I think so but he he he owned
it a couple years later I mean he was
just too much too fast he moved the guy
and he jokes about it now uh but yeah
man he got him just the dealer was like
a [__] alligator just waiting for him
to put his foot in the
pond crazy even with all the drug
dealers I robbed if you take that number
and put it in hundreds of thousands of
dollars and the amount of drug dealer I
gave money to I'd still be losing I'd
still give money I I snorted a lot of
coke guys I paid for a lot of Coke but I
robbed a lot of coke I got out man
before it was the one like towards the
end when I was drinking I had half Coke
but I never got I was a true blue
[__] drunk you know I've been so we
were just talking about this 12 and a
half years but towards the end that's
what really scared me was when I was
drinking and I get that fired up like I
had to have I'm like where's the [__]
man where's he at paage him again
[__] get him over here where's let's
go over there you know it's [__] 6:30
in the morning the guy's got kids
kicking his [__] door wake him up
kids you know he's probably up you know
just you all logic [__] goes you know
all my madness was motivated
by Bombay Sapphire Jin and Tequila but
once the cocaine got in there I'm like
we got to push this car off of [__]
moha
I rented a car I'm like take me up to M
Holland Brian Trum who's owns a bar
downtown he's like all right let's go
we're up on M Holland we're out we're
pushing the car he's like what are we
doing it's 4 in the morning we're going
to launch this [__] thing off the
cliff a team style and see if this
[__] car blows up here in la oh yeah
we were up on malland over you know how
they have those oversight things you
could look see for fun yeah it was like
4 in the morning and I just moved here I
was I was I drank in La for 6 months and
then I got sober hopefully for good so
I'm like I had a rented car and it was
fully insured I'm like let's launch this
[__] thing off a cliff and see what
happens he goes what and he Dives in the
car from the passengers he we're pushing
it like it was dead you know I had it in
neutral he Dives in and pushes the
emergency break he goes I'm not walking
all the way back down the [__] Hill
he didn't give a [__] D we were going to
launch the [__] car into someone's
house he just didn't want to [__]
walk back down home yeah man it was it
was I knew if I drank out
here I saw a couple things one I'd be
dead in a year for sure but two I saw
that it was wide [__] open on the
street like no one was really pulling
any strings and I'm like if comedy
doesn't work I was on the opposite side
you were I'm like I'll just [__] jump
back in the game and just put a crew
together out here because no one's doing
anything you know I see guys in like
ascots going I'm a coke dealer I'm like
holy [__] this is the guy you're copping
from I'm like who's got you back he's
like what do you mean and I'm thinking
this guy's just walking around with
weight with loafers and a scarf and a
[__] I'm like you're just floating
around with this like no one that's what
you do there's no one you you're not
part of a crew you don't have anyone
backing you like you just went out you
know you booked a commercial and you
took 10 grand and you bought a kilo and
didn't they shoot a movie about kids
that were robbing people in the
Hollywood oh yeah oh yeah that like The
Bling Ring or something like that it's
yeah it's you know you meet these people
these people let their guards down
they're not from that environment
they're not from that Society so when
they come up with an animal and trust me
every day somebody gets hit by an animal
here in La the story if you turn on the
I almost got caught and all that [__]
you'll see that half of those stories
are La that dumped in it was an actor
and he turned this and he be a they gave
him a job as a lone mower guy in front
of somebody's house and he [__]
robbed the car it's always something you
know because it it's crazy if you don't
I take I make copies of everyone's
driver's license that comes to my house
that does handy work everyone I go I
understand you guys want a [__]
living I got a copy machine right here
give me a license and I'm going to make
it you think I'm going to [__] stay I
don't give a [__] what you think give me
a copy of your [__] license or you a
not doing the [__] work because you
can come in and you get 10% for tipping
off a score to your pal or your uncle
that just got out and he short on money
and you came in and you saw three big
screens of four MacBooks in my house and
you're getting 10% of that people clean
my house yeah so I'm like never let
nobody clean your house so I'm like hey
give me never never no Outsiders in your
house nothing we're making copies
nothing it's the weirdest thing I don't
like no Outsiders in my house like a lot
of people get cleaning services to come
in I don't want nobody in my [__]
house when I go to a hotel I I don't
want a misunderstanding let's just not
have any misunderstandings nobody in my
[__] room don't refill the snack
barall don't do nothing don't do nothing
mind your [__] business I'm leaving
on Sunday morning you can do whatever
the [__] you want I don't want nobody in
my house that's why when you would tell
me people you're Jewish that's even
worse I don't have anything in my house
doesn't matter doesn't matter you could
be sitting there one night somebody
might think you have something you got
three guys that might think you have
something and here you are tied up
getting bit slapped and they're asking
you you didn't do a [__] thing you
didn't do didn't do a [__] thing you
don't ever want anybody in your [__]
house you clean your own [__] toilet
you do everything nobody comes in my
house that doesn't NE necessarily have
to be in there we have water in the
ceiling and the guy was coming at 3:15 I
was right there with him I checked the
[__] everything I let him know he
said I'll be back Thursday can't be back
Thursday we're not going to be here I
own it and I tell him look I used to be
a [__] animal guys so I I see the
move coming and by the way not to
interrupt you it has been stroke week
online I'm going tell you people for the
last [__] time all right just in case
you got any ideas here it is I don't
want to do nobody's podcast I don't have
the [__] time if you don't live in LA
I can't do your podcast I don't Skype I
don't know what the [__] I'm doing next
I don't know I don't know and now I got
to get a hold of you and tell you I
can't do your stupid [__] podcast
let's just stop now don't hit me up for
podcast I don't want you to hook me up I
don't want to do dick when I go to a
[__] town to do comedy I don't want
to be [__] bothered number two if you
want me to sponsor you it's all about
cash okay don't tell me what I could
make that [__] jerk off the other day
you could make 30,000 selling websites
really go sell [__] websites then
show me one guy that's making 30,000 he
thinks like I'm some [__] Momo well
you could make that well all right well
if I can make 30,000 let's do this it's
commission right yeah You' made 30,000
yeah all the time send me 15 and you can
sponsor the show I don't want 30 you
made 30 right yeah good we want eight of
that eight Fair okay if you don't have
eight of that 30 you ain't real bye
today I got a guy I made Oprah
Millions I'm the guy that made
Oprah I want to put a tour together but
he wants to get no no and the guy was
serious I should have taken this [__]
email and read this [__] thing he
wants to put a comedy he put down what
Russell Peters made last year what Jerry
Seinfeld made what all the top comics
made they said that if we do a tour we
can make more money than these guys and
we're funny than that but he wants to do
a tour with all these attractions like
we're want to pull somebody who got
arrested in that area and to the stage
and yell at him and embarrass him and
tape it like right away you're like are
you [__] [__] he went from opr to
grabbing felons out of the audience
audience somebody somebody tweeted at me
this week and I'm sure he's nice but he
said when you when Joey comes to Indie
you should you guys should do a podcast
from the prison for the inmates mind you
[__]
Johny listen let me tell you something
these people with all their [__]
ideas these people think that you just
call up a prison yeah and go hi is Joey
Diaz and my friend leis sayette and we
want to come and do a podcast oh D enx
would love that when do you want to do
it let me book you in cuz our goal here
is to
make are you [__] stupid and that's
you got to ask those people go are you
[__] just ask I know I'm sure a nice
guy he ain't a nice guy he's a dummy
because who would think who wants to go
to a [__] what makes you think I want to
go inside a [__] prison and do a
podcast with a bunch of people are
looking at my neck that's what they're
looking at they're looking at your
[__] neck going look at that guy he
eats good I can smell the I could smell
the [__] sausage from his [__]
ears please people just leave me the
[__] alone I got a wife I got a kid I'm
trying to get healthy I'm trying to
write a book I'm trying to write jokes I
got a podcast I got to communicate with
friends and and and loved ones around
here I don't have time to call you
during the week guy I don't I don't even
know what my next [__] move is today
I had a guy hit me up on Facebook go to
my Facebook page hi you did a podcast
with a gentleman I think it was Burke
ker and you said something about the
government what's the name of that
agency are you
[__] I don't know what I said on the
podcast yesterday what the [__] are you
talking about what I said that you don't
even know who the [__] guest I even
know who the guest was at least you can
go to f Twitter or something yeah oh
boy yeah it's not it's did you respond
yeah you went back you went back and
forth with him what I say to him okay do
you want me to read the the thing he
wrote Whatever Lee read something you
[__] Jesus you want me to read that
thing no resp we had a lot of momentum
going there until you threw [__]
stick right in the spokes his response
was my brother I don't remember what I
said yesterday never mind two months ago
dot dot dot that's all he responded with
and what did he say thanks for the
honesty the [__] you me to tell
him the [__] is wrong with these
people thanks for the
honesty you [__] J Hey Joe you do my
podcast yeah not you your family I can
drive to your house I know I'm saying
these guys you ever do that though
you're talking to a guy and you're [__]
you're just vulnerable for a moment in
front of him you're like man these
[__] and you stop and then they
ask you for the exact same thing that
you just went on a [__] rant for 10
minutes all the time and you're like
will you not listening all the [__]
time to what I [__] just said for the
last 10 minutes all the time I don't
have the time if I had the time I'd do
them I did I did Doug bensons at 4 in
the afternoon I had to cancel two
[__] things I don't have the [__]
time guys I barely have the time for
this why you think we're doing on
Tuesday night at 8 [__] o'clock
because [__] develops and you know I got
four [__] days in town I got three
days in town the next two weeks so my
time where you going this weekend what
you playing bual New York [__] [__]
beef on Wick couple diet [__] Wings
diet Wings they got diet Wings in
Buffalo that's how they playing helium
the only they only got one [__] club
up there I mean they don't have [__]
they had the little chubby lesbian [__]
but she moved to open up a roller skate
rink or some [__] who the [__] knows she
bounced a few checks that was over for
her gotta go yeah once you bounce a
check in the comedy business it's tough
taking a call you know what I'm saying
it's tough for
somebody n i mean what were we talking
about where you gonna go this week
you're in Buffalo no before that we talk
of myself oh some guy drug dealers drug
and then people asking you to do podcast
yeah podcast you know businesses people
want to start businesses hi how you
doing you want to start a business yeah
yeah I just met you on Gmail yeah I'm
dying to [__] start a business with
you all right get the [__] out of here
[__] what the [__] is wrong with you
every wants to start oh you should come
to Denver and start a weed business all
right I'll do it
tomorrow yeah I got nothing better to do
but to fly back and [__] forward I
can't stop looking at my child yeah
that's you know what I'm saying who the
[__] wants to stop looking at your kid
one day you're going to get you're going
to get the wife pregnant you're you're
going to look at your kid you can't take
your eyes off them nothing means the
same nothing you don't I don't give a
[__] what I want to hear What story do
you want to tell me I got to sit there
and listen to you do a [__] podcast
in a basement with your mother up there
cooking goulash or some [__] and a waste
of your time is no longer a waste of
your time it's a waste my time I don't
have the [__] time you know some guys
last week you call to the show on Sunday
listen guy on Sunday I do this thing at
10:00 I get out at 11:00 11:30 I got to
drive back whatever time my wife gets
out of church with the kid we got to go
eat yeah so if your podcast has to
interfere with eating you're not going
to get the call can I be that honest
with you well if you could did you just
not [__] hear what I told you guys
that if I'm with them I can't pick up
the [__] phone and call you I can't
it's impossible I'm with my daughter in
the [__] wife of the restaurant and
you want to ask me who's going to win
Anderson Silva against Diaz I don't give
a [__] I really don't even give a [__] I
don't give a [__] it's going to be Silva
by the way who gives a [__] you know
what I'm saying I don't give a
[__] you know people want you to give a
[__] about things and that's the problem
as you as you get older you don't give a
[__] you like how did I waste all that
time doing that watching that stupidity
and doing this and doing that you start
narrowing it down I just got a flip
phone during the day I think I told you
so I forward my iPhone calls to the flip
phone from 10 to put the thing away
please put the thing away you make me
nervous yeah yeah that means the feds
are watching you put the [__] thing hold
on just look right in this little hole
right here put the thing away you make
me nervous at the [__] phone it's the
size of a [__] house well I know
people have asked you to do Biggest
Loser and do you see what happened
recently with them nobody asked me to do
Biggest Loser has people no not not them
but like people keep saying you should
go on it yeah but they do a police
background check really yeah they don't
want none of that [__] oh okay nobody's
ever said it to me cuz they know I won't
do that [__] then I don't do that stuff
Le what makes you think I want to be on
TV with a bunch of homos look at me I
Need A protein that Jillian Michaels the
queen of the Jews whipping me and [__]
telling me to lose weight go [__]
yourself before I [__] call the man
to steal the [__] is wrong with these
people [__] obvious loser whatever
the [__] Biggest Loser
I'm the [__] it is with a bunch of
Gentile this is fun get the [__] out of
here I was just telling you guys before
the show I did that AR show the other
night the uh this is not happen the
this is not happening you know I'm a
professional and I try to be a
professional but I also have another
problem I'm not a [__] fake and I
went to this thing the other day on
Saturday night I was in a great mood
when I went down I had a story in my
head I was going to do a story about
revenge when me and Tommy Russo and Dey
Cano beat up this [__] jerk off with
a whiffle ball bat by Nick's
Pizza and I get there and right the away
I started seeing industry people but
like industry people that I've known
throughout the years and they if if I if
a train fell out of the sky they they
want the train to hit me like they've
tried really hard not to even avoid me
but to [__] with me at every obvious
Point couple of these [__] I saw down
there you know two [__] in particular
and a couple guys you know that work for
Comedy Central they do whatever they do
they have that little [__] job which
they have no Talent at all they don't do
nothing they don't even know what talent
is they know what people tell them you
know what I'm saying when they're
sitting in a group and oh my God I seen
hand oh he you know they just agree with
what everybody else agrees with that's
it and they go to each other when you go
to that uh it's not whatever the [__]
when we go to the this is not happening
and the little Comedy Central Comics go
up with their dumb [__] stories and
you see the Comedy Central
people there's their boys when we go up
they sit there Stone Face like looking
at them you can see these [__]
have hatred for the real people they're
not real and this is what I forget that
these people are part of a fake [__]
they have no they were raised fake their
parents were fake you know what I'm
saying they've been fake all their lives
they've been seeing people go you know
your P people come over and they're like
oh my God it's so nice to have you over
then when they close the door like well
lucky they left they saw that as
children so they bring that they start
doing that also they start telling
people oh my God no listen you're a
[__] [__] let me bring hummus to
my [__] house again when your child
sees that he gets it when your child
sees that you don't have to be nice to
people that they rather hear the truth
sometimes people rather hear the truth I
rather when my wife makes me a dinner if
it's spectacular I'll suck a [__]
[__] 10 times but if the food isn't
that good I'll tell her the truth I say
honey I didn't like that meal I didn't
like how you cook it so she doesn't keep
doing it so I don't get myself into a
personal r as a human being and I have
to lie to her and now every six weeks
she like I made your favorites they're
not my [__] favorites I don't like
that [__] you know and I'm like that
with everybody but that's how I was
raised I saw my mother be real with
people I saw my mother at a bar tell
people instead of what they wanted to
hear she didn't care about the customer
she didn't care about listen I don't
like you I don't want you in my bar I
just don't like you man and you don't
like me and you've talked about me so
why would you want to drink in get the
[__] out of my bar I saw my mom do that
and I put two and two together what a
real person is like what my mother
wanted me to be like so when I get
around those people I get angry I it
just makes my [__] and now that I've
been in La all these years I react to
them different and the other night I let
them take me down with their evil and
with their Kiss of Death prowers yeah I
let them take me down and that's why I
bombed at that show and guys I got the
[__] right off the stage I didn't even
say good night to anybody like I didn't
want to say goodbye to I just hate those
people now like I have no use for
fakeness for telling somebody hey that
was great no it wasn't why you lying to
him why are you lying to him when I get
off stage I know if I bombed you want to
come up to me tell me that was great I
even get pissed at people when they come
up to me go that was a great set no it
wasn't yeah that set sucked okay I I
saved it somewhere along the line but I
did the same jokes or whatever I'm just
one of those people so it changes the uh
tone of the audience for sure you know
what I mean if that's part of it cuz an
audience isn't going to judge it that
hard no matter what you know what I mean
it's like stock Brokers you know sitting
in
aention you know what do you mean unless
it's like a bombing bombing we've sat
you've sat in a thousand bad shows Lee
that some have included me and some have
included some of your favorite [__]
Comics you've paid 60 and $70 to go to
those festivals and you've come back and
told me the truth that this person
sucked this person sucked Festival that
takes a lot of character because
nobody's going to pay $60 and come back
and tell you it sucks that's why there's
so many Exquisite restaurants they suck
half of these restaurants you go to they
suck you go in there you're like I don't
know what the [__] they're thinking but
they suck but nobody's ever going to
tell you something sucks when they put
$100 investment the woman is definitely
not going to tell you everything to them
is [__] great you know they eat dirt
wrapped up in the [__] tamale oh this
is great was great no it wasn't shut the
[__] up before I smack you it sucks shut
up you filming or no what's that were
you filming for the the show or no what
show the one you just said you did he
did you did already show but this was at
theal right this is at the
festival the show no I tap you already
taped it I seen it on YouTube yeah yeah
I taped the show uh we taped two of them
and then now we're doing a TV one so
yeah so you that was just a li that was
a throwaway though right was a throw
yeah I didn't give a [__] no no no I not
a throwaway but you don't have to
[__] go up and hit a [__] home run
cuz the Camas are on no no no I don't
give a [__] I just did it because I
wanted to help Ari he's my friend but
once I went down I saw the people that
were saying hello to them and creepy
people like some girl came up to him we
were having a conversation some girl
came didn't give a [__] hi do you know
how I am guess and I's play like listen
did you I see him having a [__]
conversation here I he's like uh I don't
know I'm Susan whatever's uh assistant
really you're an assistant you're coming
to say hello get the [__] out of my face
with some white dude with a blue shirt
on with ugly shoes on and he was just
standing there like she was dead beat
and he was a bigger [__] dead beat
you know and they're spreading their
dead Bea this around get the [__] in the
seat with that popcorn of the [__]
Saturday night eating popcorn the [__]
out of here there's booze there's heroin
you're around the block from downtown
Town you're [__] eating popcorn but
why didn't why didn't you just do the
story that cuz you you've said we've
talked before about how like if there's
older people in the audience you used to
get nervous and you don't anymore so why
did you let them change your
story know what's weird satisfaction
yeah I think it's a weird thing it's a
generate when we came up there was a
weird thing where some somehow your P
the power shift just came and it just
[__] with you from being a young comic I
don't know if you share but it sounds
like the same thing and then you got to
get on the other side where you just go
I I don't give a [__] I'm going to do
what I'm going to do anyway you know
what I mean cuz I did a showcase one
time and it was like you're already
starting at a disadvantage and you could
you know when you go up and you're
performing for an audience you could you
could feel where the audience is at and
you're like don't you want this to go
your way I mean if we collaborate on
this we get the best result like you
trying to break me isn't good for either
one of us on a business level you feel
me but but that's not the approach it's
always like you [__] jump through
hoops and you prove it to me I'm already
here man I'll never forget I walked off
stage to a standing ovation at The
Improv in
2004 and the executive from a network
was in the back and I'm on cloud n and
I'm high-fiving people just a magical
set and I go what do you think of that I
just happen to see him he was standing
by those double doors that open by the
sound booth and he goes I go look look
and I'm W people have turned to watch me
walk out of the room and I'm waving to
him and I go what do you think of that
he goes I don't know what to do with
that and I go what are you talking about
he goes I don't know how to I don't know
I go look that's your audience that's
who watches your network what do you
mean you don't know I don't know how to
cuz Downey wouldn't buy advertising I'm
like what do you mean you don't that's
the people that buy things what are you
talking about and then we went outside
he's like I just don't know how to
translate that into a television show
and I go well that's where we go and we
meet with writers and showrunners and we
pair it up and I tell you more stories
and we p i mean the business is now
wasn't this just to let you know what
I'm capable of on a comedy level and you
just saw it every it wasn't a person
that stayed in the seat too much work
yeah it was like it was it was a it was
a bizarre confusing puzzle and it was
weird that I think it's shifting now
because of social media like did the
Radford Hall uh show Saturday night sold
out standing room only sold out there
the show I don't need somebody to tell
me that I'm funny anymore I don't I
don't need that come to my show you know
you are thank you again for making me a
part of your show you know invite me to
come out and do standup I perform for
your audience so my job that night
wasn't like hey everybody [__] look
at how funny I am it was I'm going to be
funny for you for your headliner coming
on I'm going to do my little dance I'm
going to give you my goods for 15
minutes perform to the top of my
capabilities but Uncle Joey's closing it
out and it's his show and it's his night
old school style you know what I mean
you don't want to come on and scoop
everything up that was great man by the
way that was a your your audience is the
[__] well these got these podcast people
listen now you're getting people that
coming to the shows and they know what
you're about 10 years ago you going up
on stage cold you said two words that
were wrong you turned off half the
audience now you're fighting [__]
Upstream we don't have that problem no
more people are coming out and I
appreciate them I could give them a
better show they know where we're coming
from exactly there's nobody getting
upset we did a [__] live podcast at
the laugh faction second one it was
horrifically because half the people
there didn't belong because the Laugh
Factory Market it wrong they thought it
was a standup show I told the Laugh
Factory 15 [__] times the Laugh
Factory I never dealt with nothing like
that me and Lee have had this
conversation on podcast for three weeks
I'll half these Club managers don't know
what a [__] podcast is they don't
know how to pckage it so do me a favor
just leave it alone yeah don't touch it
just make believe we're coming in on
Wednesday night we're going to do what
we're going to do or don't book it and
then try to make it your thing it's your
thing it's this is your guys show you
bring it in don't don't be like make it
like this go [__] yourself they call me
oh well who's kind the show who's doing
standup how many minutes are people
doing the pce it's a podcast so does
that mean six people go up or S I was
like I don't believe
this I do not [__] believe this [__]
that's like the last thing that's
holding people back is you it's still
it's too expensive to book theaters so
you still have to deal with some of
these people but once someone figures
out a way to have music venues Lee
they're doing music venues now yeah you
go in on a night like on a Monday when
it's dark you do 100 seats at 20 bucks a
pop and you keep the door the can you
like that could you tour like like
headlining comedians tour and still make
close to the same money yeah I tell you
what when you're doing those Rock clubs
you earn every dollar it's [__] shoot
them up Sally if they know you're coming
though I'm saying you do those club with
your audience because they're
standing it's a lot of [__] there's no
door people it's not the emperor so you
earn your money but you lose it's it's
[__] crazy you know Stan hope did it
for a while and it worked for him yeah
but his audience that's what they are
you know yeah most people Rogan people
you know they don't mind to go that [__]
that's why he stopped doing the House of
Blues you know he wouldn't let them
stand up and they said no I don't want
people stand up in my show you want to
stand up with
bro after 20 minutes I just paid [__]
bucks I'm standing up you got to rent
chairs you just take it out of the door
you rent 300 chairs 200 chairs whatever
and you put chairs in there you got to
put chairs you know you got to sit down
people have to relax I don't want people
sitting up yelling woo no waitresses
they got to walk back and forth that
adds a different touch to it that adds a
complete different feel when there's no
waitress and you're losing them are
there only are there only corporate
comedy clubs or are there like
individual comedy clubs there's
individual ones but do like main like a
level Headliners go
there if you're the only me and you
opened up a club in [__] Detroit
uhhuh and we paid the comment and we
hooked up with gers and CAA and we paid
their fees we get whatever comic we want
okay but when you see their fees you're
going to have a heart attack
really you know because to really make
it you got to have the big guys come in
that sell tickets those guys want money
they also want a white limo they also
want eight hotel rooms for their friends
and family oh plus you have all this
advertising you're doing which
advertising is out the [__] roof
right now that's why when I get an email
from somebody telling me about how easy
it is to put a tour together I giggle my
ass off didn't Funny or Die habit tour
with all the Gentiles of Comedy right
with Whitney Cummings and you know
what's his name uh the guy you know Step
Brothers and everybody was on the tour
what happened and Nick Swanson what
happened
what happened to the tour the Oddball
tour no the other one they did they did
funny or die did a tour two three years
ago okay and you know touring is hard
because you got five [__] Egos and
their agents are part of it so your
tickets are going to be 85 [__]
dollar $100 for five EOS you ever go see
five EOS on stage it's the dumbest thing
you'll ever seen your life people don't
go see five [__] five's too much anyway
for one show for one show unless the
show's running two and hours which means
it's a half an hour too long which means
five people chopping up 20 minutes
everyone every's going to go over the
light yeah and everyone's going
everybody that's why I don't want to be
part of boy bands that's why you don't
want to be part of those tours you know
t-shirts I'd rather not I like doing it
small keep I like I'm a microeconomic
type of [__] you know what I'm
saying I'm not a macro type of
[__] of ay I rather keep it
small keep the prices low I want the
people to go home and felt like they got
a bar bargain if I charge him 30 they're
going to go that wasn't a bargain he
sucked but if I charge him 20 18 that's
a [__] bargain guy and I want that I
don't need to make [__] money off
doing that [__] I don't really it drives
me crazy once the business angle of it
comes on and these agents will call you
I got a call last week we're going to do
$35 tickets well cancel me yeah well how
about 30 cancel me how much are tickets
22 is the top ticket I charged that's
probably where it's probably 20 with the
service fee so that's probably what's
bring
yeah 22 that's it I don't give a [__]
don't don't Buck me then I don't believe
in that I don't believe a a comedy club
should a person should pay oh I don't
believe it cuz they got to get a
babysitter they got to get Val they got
I just don't want it I don't want that I
don't want that you know I don't need
$25 30 for these shirts $20 that's it I
don't need all this you know to to to
destroy people I never had that desire I
didn't want people to come oh a shirt
this that th no I don't even give a [__]
if you buy a shirt just come to the
[__] show let's laugh let's smoke
dope afterward and go the [__] home
we'll take a picture that's all I want
out of these people you know what I'm
saying Lee what's the matter with you no
I'm [__] up how are you [__] up cuz
you put hash in there no I didn't put no
has yes you did no I didn't you've been
putting hash in for like two weeks you
have like little exciting periods what
happened to you last night you got
stoned oh my God I got stoned I went to
the I I forced myself to go to the gym
at 9:00 I got a little bit UNH high or a
little bit sober did you sweat some of
that THC out at the gym yeah did you
smell it coming out of your [__] no
but I had to turn off Scarface cuz I
thought the he was going to smack his
wife and it gave me I started pan having
a panic attack on the elliptical so I
telling me that to you don't like to see
women get smacked it freaks me out but
you'll watch porno and see them get
[__] in the ass and Cal on their
titties yeah I don't know there's some
you see what I'm saying there's
something about like seeing a girl get
smacked in the face freaks me out I'm
going give some shout outs here right
miles Babs I love you [__] Fred
Nar stop asking you you're [__]
disgusting Peter ho Quinn Amy who loves
you 420 Malibu Zelda you bad
[__] Raised by Wolves and Lauren
rosener I love you guys always yeah
Peter Fred n stop you're embarrassing
you know what I'm saying one time I did
it because you're a [__] pain the ass
you know what I'm saying what's up Lee
what do you got planned for tonight
where you going to go tonight I got
nothing you going to go you get some
cheeseburgers how many calories you got
left tonight you're not going to eat
tonight this don't do nothing to you oh
yes it does, calories I only how do you
have a th000 [__] calories at night
I'll tell you why because I had to take
a sleeping pill at 600 in the morning so
I didn't wake up till noon so I had I
had one Subway sandwich today and then I
had two other podcasts that's how he's a
thousand he woke up an hour ago yeah
pretty much so yeah so I still have
something left cuz every time I get this
High I have to eat why'd you eat a
Subway sandwich you didn't go to big
mice
after everything we went through you
didn't go to Jersey M you're back at
that dump I had two I I had three
podcasts today I had to go to the gym
there a jersey mice around the corner
what happened it was frizzling out on me
again what's easier you got [__] food
in no don't go there to push we used to
go there when we first started working
why would you go to Subway you got
that's it it's over no more Subway
you're a jersey mice guy now okay that's
it it was pretty good that's it no more
Subway
that's the new rule in the house no more
so I don't want to hear that [__] you're
a jersey mik guy get a regular sandwich
no chips and get a dyet soda no be fine
I do it all the [__] time tuna with a
little onion hold the vinegar all with a
little mayo you're fine they got the
turkey nice turkey real turkey with
proone cheese you put some lettuce you
put some mayonnaise salt and pepper it's
a beautiful [__] sandwich no more
Subway guy that's it you're a man you're
a church [__] evaluator you're the
[__] guest host of the CH how you
eating that disgusting [__] people are
looking at you no more of that [__] you
got Jersey mics right around the corner
bro right around the corner why do you
hate America he hates he loves that
pepperoni he goes in there and he gets
that pepperoni from in there I get
pepperoni from the Del counter what's
the name of your Al-Qaeda cell what you
get pepperoni at the [__] Subway yeah
with nothing I get
mustard no more pepperon no more Subway
it's over unbelievable you are a jersey
mic guy now you're from the East [__]
Coast guy you got to start acting like
you got to start eating topnotch food no
more silliness for you there's a busload
of grandmothers that just perished
because of you're in subordination no
more of this [__] you're an East Coast
guy bro you got to act an East Coast guy
but you're a huge fan of that cheese and
veggies sandwich no I don't no I don't I
don't go in there when I'm on the road
making $6 a week I'm a big fan of
it why would I go in there when you go
get tub and a sub the [__] the thing
what you tub and a sub CU and a sub is a
salad at Jersey Mike okay she get the
same sandwich without the bread so don't
tell me about calorie I want to lose
weight n [__] that [__] that's poison
that's poison how many times when we
[__] and not every rose has its storm
poison poison po poison it's [__] bad
for you it's turkey [__] pastrami
it's turkey [__] salami it's turkey
[__] pepperoni what part of that
don't you [__] understand but what's
wrong with turkey because you want to
eat the real [__] you're from the East
Coast guy you're from Boston you start
acting like it eats cheddar cheese who
eats cheddar cheese on his sandwiches no
they don't that's for [__] white
Gentiles that eat ranch and they and
they believe the reviews to a movie oh
my God F Stars you know that's what
that's for no more cheddar American
sliced thin Swiss sliced thin white
white the American white oh he don't
[__] know American sliced in land the
Lakes what are you [__] nuts it's
like butter a little provalone when that
cheese melt that cheddar cheese squeeze
a pimp on your face you see the cheddar
fly out of your [__] face
[__] that's what cheddar cheese is
disgust nobody goes when was the last
time you went to a sandwich a place even
[__] Subway they sell cheddar cheese
there no there's a reason whatever your
[__] name is there's a reason why
people you don't put cheddar cheese on a
sandwich never like avocado yeah if you
need it like if you're half a [__] like
if you're gluten-free who puts avocado
on their [__] sandwiches when you go
to Jersey is there any [__] sandwich
with avocado on no no then why would you
put avocado on your [__] sandwich cuz
we're in California when you go to
Boston is there avocado when you go to
Legal
Seafood can I get no they look at you
and go are you [__] [__] are you
[__] [__] or just taking [__]
lessons this is every week when I want
to write something funny I call him and
ask him what he ate that day that's all
I got to do is call him what' you eat
today
he what of te he got mad cuz I had
Korean dumblings what's wrong with
Korean because there's 20,000 Chinese
places right up here around the corner
every week his girlfriend talks him into
going to some exotic place to be Johnny
exotic it's downtown on the train exotic
on the train again you're from the East
Coast all right if you want to take
trains you move to New York nobody takes
RS you go right over here you go to that
Chinese place up the corner here there's
a Korean place on Laurel Canyon you keep
it over here and you take a rick shot
from one to the
other that's it it's over no more Subway
for you that's it you've been eating
Subway for too long your generation's
[__] [__] no more Subway no more
avocado no more bacon on Burgers what is
wrong with you [__] people that's a
double colopy what is that called like a
double if you wrote a sentence what is
that called
redundant being redundant yeah that's
being
redundant redundant you know this [__]
with the club who eats a club sandwich
in New Jersey with avocado you can't
order his club sandwich on these a club
sandwich I don't not eat a [__] club
sandwich bab place my wife ordered a
[__] club sandwich my wife went to
the my wife went to the uh but it was an
East Coast Club an East Coast white
bread toasted BLT Club
mayonnaise crispy almost burnt bacon
I'll [__] you turkey and toothpick
the top triple layer triple layer and it
was tight up at the [__] uh where the
USC the bowlers across they have the
kids space Oh yeah yeah the [__] the
kitchen was tremendous my wife got that
she right away she's a [__] Gentile
let me get a club sandwich I was going
to smack that but you know what are you
going to do but then when I saw it I'm
like holy [__] it looks like an East
Coast B L with toothpicks toast they cut
it nice then little triangles but that
[__] you eat chicken with bacon avocado
I see you I see you I see you the other
night listen to what happened twice
already a nice nice people sent us a a
Christmas present $125 to go eat a
[__] what's the name of the place a
steak place I forget yeah you forget
Ruth Chris oh that's nice both times I
offer him to him and his girlfriend one
night they were going to Pizza my
girlfriend wanted Pizza I would smack
the [__] out of her that's when I go to
her okay I'm going to order you pizza
but I'm going by myself cuz you got to
set your marker and
enforcedly you she doesn't like steak
why would I waste who gives a [__] what
she likes who gives a [__] what she
likes they got [__] shrimp there they
got everything they'd probably make you
Pizza they got everything there Ruth
Chris look at the [__] menu go to
Ruth Chris look at the [__] appetizer
menu they got they but why would I waste
it if she doesn't like it why doesn't
matter what she likes I don't care if
she drinks water as long as she watches
you eat the [__] steak what do you
give a [__] you turned down a pizza from
Laurel Canyon he's from the East Coast
would you straighten him out it's a go
ahead it's a it's a brick upen place
it's a brick can't yeah that's a pry
that's a party F you can't if a guy's
saying let's go get steaks I gave him my
card I said take the card take and throw
a steak down her [__]
throat let me tell you still haven't
used a card no he has a card I said come
get it take it out yeah then I called
him again what are you guys going to do
I go Lee I'm busy the next couple weeks
just come get the car take it around I
call you back oh my God she doesn't like
steak Who again who gives a [__] what
she likes Lee when was the last time was
why was nice pres who gives a [__] then
you give her a [__] appetizer what's
the appetizers read the appetizers do
you like steak Lee I do love steak okay
that's all that [__] matters do you
do things that she likes no he does it
all the time coconut macaroons one what
I'm saying could isn't there a reciproc
isn't there a reciprocation fck be the
Captain Kirk here's already said well
she doesn't like it listen if you don't
like it I'll drop you off at Mom's I'll
go by myself and get a [__] $100
steak on my own that's where you call
your boys [__] down dog you late the
LA I don't give a [__] what you like
what's on the menu what I forget the
name of it already read the [__] menu
Ruth Chris read the [__] thing menu
let's find it Ruth Chris it's delicious
I'm sure it is they Pan seere the steaks
we got steak before I like steak but I
didn't want to waste her gift what gift
you said it was a gift card it's a gift
you're going to take her you're going to
throw something down her throat and they
got to take they got fish they got a lot
of good things yeah she don't like none
of those [__] main dishes read the
main dishes to
me let's see read the main dishes she
don't like none of those dishes that's
what you're trying barbecue shrimp okay
lamb chops okay chicken breast she don't
like none of that either right what else
don't she like she hates awesome what
else that's what they they have lobster
they got on stuff and she don't like
none of that she' rather eat a [__]
Pizza no you have to explain to her what
the [__] you're going to eat
tonight for free for free a steak dinner
for free lobster for
free yeah travesty of American Justice
what did you eat the second time I
called that night tell them I forget
what night it was the second time last
week when I called the Chinese
place she wanted to go get Chinese we
went to together again it doesn't listen
I like Chinese too the Chinese on your
own [__] time Uncle Joey gave me a
Ruth Chris you got to go you got to go
100% you got to go we're going that's it
put your shoes on let's go I don't
really think night out you get to dress
up a little bit it's kind of chicken
they got barbecue shrimp you're going to
like it this is Ruth Chris this is white
people these are white people when you
going to be around white these are
people going to protect and serve these
are the people you got to be around
these are [__] white people well I
don't get up you're going shut the [__]
up get
dressed the
[__] this is what I got to deal with
this this is my stepson this is what God
is inherited me and he has the ball make
these rules and then you break them I
don't make no rules and break them you
just said what is with bacon on
sandwiches and you had you ate a club
sandwich because your wife got one
before before that when was the last
time I ate a club I don't know never Lee
BLT is the only thing I ate it with
bacon on you're not a fan of the bacon
I'm a fan of bacon but not on everything
like this new generation yeah you don't
need it it's like you don't need it the
double nun Tundra whatever if you can so
you're just saying bacon byy itself how
you bacon listen I'll get Oscar Maya
thin cut bacon yeah smoke a jint i atat
the whole package if it's fried
deliciously I eat it Soo with butter
I'll dip my bacon in butter okay Dr
butter I don't give a [__] what it's
like just on the on the stick I love
[__] bacon okay cha butter one bite
of bacon but this new White America they
think they got to put bacon on
everything yeah it's it's [__]
mindboggling it's a club club what club
I took a little little brown sugar and a
little Dijon mustard he was telling I
whip it up put the bacon on a baking
sheet slather that little mixture on the
top 450 come out bacon
sticks if I told him I made cinnamon
glazed bacon he would come over and let
the air out of my tires no he just being
nice to you he would you eat would you
eat Dijon cinnamon bacon not cinnamon
brown sugar oh brown sugar sorry
cinnamon you don't put cinnamon on bacon
I miss the East Coast that's what I'm
saying to you though that's it enough no
more of this [__] you should go back to
East Coast [__] eatting now it's an
representative bro you can't turn into
one of these [__] people out here you
got to go to Ruth Chris [__] great
this
[__] he won't do nothing New England
P how long you guys been together a year
and a yeah that's it smacking people you
got to start telling them listen this is
what's going on ug boots Speedos and a
[__] cake we going to eat this right
now well I don't like I don't care what
you like this this is what we're do with
I'm the captain kir of this Enterprise
last time I [__] checked all right a
sea Trident last time I checked I'm the
[__] man here the [__] what you like
Aviation
goggles that's right ugs speo and
Aviation goggles with a sea Trident like
a [__]
Champion roll the skates sparklers I'm
going to do this and then I'm going to
end up sleeping on your couch you're not
going to do nothing that's that's how
you get respect if not they push you
over then they'll say I got no chance
look at look at [__] your boy he's
got no girlfriend now cuz he he's no you
got to [__] step it up that's a great
night on the time especially woman you
got to step it up dog you got [__] good
people watching the energy in the place
is phenomenal the service two times
[__] the first time for a pizza I
almost died like my feelings Hur like a
[__] pizza but can you tell the whole
story at least give me some credit yeah
man we had plans onza plants we've been
dieting since June and we wanted Pizza
who gives a [__] you mean this could
have been your cheat
this is even worse listen to this listen
to this listen a cheap meal you took
Pizza over a full ride to not dominoes
it was but yeah she doesn't like steak
this is not the East Coast so you can
live without the pizza I eat pizza every
90 days it don't matter I'm not eating
East Coast Pizza so why am I wasting my
calories on West Coast [__] Pizza
there's no pizza like the one I grew up
with so I refuse to eat it nothing that
[__] you guys sent me to that that [__]
lur was garbage that ain't that's
garbage we got that's garbage garbage
what's your spot that L Canyon that's
garbage
Riverside yeah I think 50 [__] bucks
garbage why it was not 50 bucks
something bucks no it's not deep dish
please you really want to confuse these
people they have a hard time making
regular [__] Pizza you want to deep
dish like Chicago oh Jesus Christ brains
explode yeah yeah you're [__] crazy
Ash for jire out here the guy goes what
are you talking about yeah add an
Italian deli so then I go all right well
give me the uh give me some beef with uh
the juice on the side give me the Yu on
the side he goes what are you talking
about the beef doesn't have
any uh some place out in Ino somebody's
like this is the deli you got to go
there this is the Italian deli is that
where Steve Timone brought you uh no it
a paline it's a music guy so I go in
there and I go all right give me some
beef with the aou on the side he go cuz
I wanted tell him so you could go
Domingos Domingos oh it's really good V
Ando that's meatball all right let's do
it but if you want a nice hot juice
sandwich roma roma right up the corner
we used to always go to Roma in
Hollywood no not a dip the old like the
Chicago no that's not going to happen
though even if you go to John Montana's
place you're going to confuse the
Mexican his head's going to blow up then
they got a place down the corner that's
supposed to be Chicago is garbage too
I've never had deep dish pizza I'll tell
you what I'll I'll overnight some I
where should I we'll figure it out after
I'll overnight use some Lum malades
which I like a lot say it's touristy no
there's a catalog that I got got from
Chicago called Taste Chicago where they
overnight it to you wow and it tastes
when when the whenever Bears games are
on I'll I'll get some and I'll you bake
them 45 minutes comes in the pan all you
got to do is take the pizza out of the
pan lightly oil the pan put the pizza
back in 45 minutes of 450 call it a day
it's [__] magical and tastes just
like home tastes like you're sitting in
the restaurant it's [__] great and
it's not super expensive you think to
overnight Pizza you know like a [__]
baller from Chicago but like a two a two
pizza deal is like 45 bucks that's not
that bad no it's not that bad so I do
that I'll get beefs and then they got
hot dog packs so you steam the poppy
seed buns you throw the sport peppers on
there pop some celery
salt that neon green relish and Boulder
they used to have uh Mustard's Last
Stand that was a Chicago place and they
put the pickles in there [__] Peppers
googly
moogly it's so [__] good you had a
combo didn't you when you were in
Chicago oh I always get the [__] I'm
going to San Diego this weekend and
Steve Simone has me going to Portillos
on the way back oh yeah get the [__]
um cake shake did he tell you about that
no what's that they throw a piece of
chocolate cake in the shake and when
you when you're drinking it why are you
going on the way back big big chunks of
the shake come through way there it's
only 20 minutes from here they give you
a Big Y it's Orange County he said it's
lamra lra 30 minutes from it's fast I've
been there
yeah cake shake man if you order
something bad and embarrass me and there
[__] Paula order something tell get
and this is all Paula gets get a combo
she's not going to get the combo go
let's get in the car why you wasting my
time let's just go to go get a burrito
cuz you're wasting my time with that
[__] this is what she needs to eat from
now on not your bolle chicken from
[__] Jersey miks you got to tell this
what you need to eat you're from the
East Coast you going to marry me I'm
from the East Coast this you got you
can't be eating that [__] around me no
tofu none of that [__] you're with me
you got to eat a beef sandwich with a
sausage what's wrong with tofu it's
either beef or sausage if she says I
don't like it then let's get back in the
car you're wasting my time going
embarrass me in here like it's like
having a tractor trailer load of dicks
slamming in your mouth that's what's
wrong with tofu I just like seeing his
face turn red unless that's a a good
thing for you at which point I mean the
opposite of that it taking me 12 years
to take my wife back east and I've
already told her when we go in November
this is what you could eat and this is
what you can't eat if you order this
[__] you're going to embarrass me I'll
give you elbow
right you think I'm kidding you you
order Felino Alfredo that white will you
you understand me and when I'm in the
east coast you order F Alfredo's white
yes you order the proper [__] nobody
[__] Italian Eats fuccini Alfredo
that's a dish invented with Gentiles you
got to get the combo with provolone you
can get red sauce with jarder on it or
they you could call it with hot dipped
with a hot dog on the side with
everything Jesus yeah you're going deep
though and then you get a a cake shake
oh [__]
[__] I'm surprised you don't have a
problem with the cake shake and if you
if you if you're in the pocket and
you're ready to go for gold you split a
Euros with her after it's and you do the
cake shake is the
Dismount so you want to start with a
combo then you do a a hot dog like a
like a like a sorbet to clean the
pallet then you chop the
Euros Gyros if you're from New York and
Jersey and then you do the cake shake
for the
Dismount that's all Portillos then you
do a lap around the [__] restaurant
screaming I a [__] Champion I am a
descendant from Zeus sent back from the
[__] future to show everyone here how
it's
done sounds good party's over though for
a while what else is off the limits in
New York anything
stupid you need to have your own cooking
show no Korean dumplings none that [__]
welcome back to nothing stupid back to
[__] back to the
goods no papaya dogs you papaya dog when
you're in New York with that Sab I'm a
Sab guy from Old School what's that
place on 57 the cart with the uh schwam
those guys that got the yellow shirts on
you know what I'm talking about I don't
know bre I don't know nothing he doesn't
eat schwarma i e schwarma do though the
lines down the [__] block you know
what I love in New York is the I don't
mix candied [__] uh cashew those
peanuts the smell of that no I stop for
those people either they're filthy those
look disgusting oh they smell good but
they look like they're like dirty cashew
so yeah they're horrible they're filthy
4 second sh I get sabad hot dogs and
then there's this other place there's
these filthy people and they got those
steak on the stick they Marin it and put
them on the grill they give you a piece
of white bread I'll eat 10 of those
[__] in New York City that's it
no Subway no [__] well yeah not no
chain pizzas no chain nothing they have
a lot of chains in like and like I hate
Time Square that's great you don't need
nobody eats in Time Square only stiffs
nobody goes to Time Square and eats what
you think L don't worry about it you're
not going to be there I don't even know
Lombard Lombard's over on Spring and M
and Little Italy who the [__] knows I'm
not going into the city cold fire
there's only two places left that do
cold fire one's like a hipst street
place and the other's that's great I
just need pizza from rors and I'll be
just fine they've been there for 40
years you know what I'm saying yeah
that's what I don't if it ain't broke
you know they got stroli they got shrimp
parmesan who makes a shrimp parmesan
nobody Romas has been there somebody
took a picture last week and they said
I've been coming to Romas every [__]
week since I was nine and I'm 50
something K from my hometown go to Romas
for pizza Rudies for galamad or
spaghetti or whatever the [__] you want
in that realm I go for Chinese a chance
what do you do fies in Jersey don't need
to go nowhere if it's not my
neighborhood and my not going I go there
for 50 years I I trust this place I
don't need to go into the city to be
cool to drop a name when went to here
for y I don't need to do that the city's
completely different where do you like
to perform when you're in New York
Gotham yeah Gotham I don't like moving
around I'm move around here you're
always in traffic here I'm going go to
New York well there's a a slice of pizza
in Brooklyn listen that's you know what
I'm saying there's a slice of pizza in
Jersey right by my house I'm been going
there for 50 years it's [__]
delicious I haven't had strong bowling
in 20 years yeah you're not cuz not
going to get it you know it's just I'm
oldfashioned I'm oldfashioned and that's
why I use blue cheese with my wings I
wouldn't even know what Ranch is I don't
want ranch in my table if I was a
restaurant owner I wouldn't allow Ranch
in my restaurant because I don't want
the people that eat that [__] in my
restaurant do you follow me like if you
eat ranch I don't want you in my I don't
want I'd rather you not come in my
establishment they gave it to you at The
Comedy Store and I had to take it out of
the out of the tray before they handed
it to you because you would have thrown
a panic attack no I just don't you know
it's like if you put ranch with wings
you've got it you've got life completely
wrong you've got life completely [__]
wrong that does kind of suck when you
call and get wings and they say I I'll
say like extra blue cheese and then it's
Ranch and right there you go listen
let's cancel the order cuz there's no
reason to get it if you had if you could
choose the type of blue cheese do you go
with the blue cheese that's just
straight creamy or with the crumbly I
want the crumbles cuz the wing has to
have the crumble when you bite into the
wing you got to bite into that blue
cheese that's the whole [__] P same
thing with the celery you're dipping
that [__] celery a little nugget in
there oh my God that's every [__]
celery stick has to have a piece of
nugget it first time I hear ran like the
Irvine Improv Ranch what are you talking
about I don't want to perform here I
don't F I want to perform here this is
embarrassing
ranch ranch anywhere is just if you have
Ranch in your establishment I don't want
to do business with you because I know
the type of person you are what does
that entail the type of person what is
the
ranch I don't like blue yeah you know
the ranch people all the ranch people
are the same they're all nosy and
[__] you know they're all [__]
like he won't let somebody at the table
get it with him no go somewhere else
bro go somewhere else you know better
you did you told somebody not to sit
next to you on Southwest cuz they had
food
yeah what do you mean they were ordering
food yeah some [__] filthy [__]
idiot some chick that thought she was
cool
that was smacking her boyfriend around
to do everything and and I was sitting
in this thing so I had two seats here
first of all I don't want a middle seat
why you want to sit here the rest of the
plane is open it's like when you're in a
restaurant you're sitting with your
family and the whole restaurant's empty
and and they sit people next to you
why'd you do that get them the [__] out
of here get them out of here that's why
I don't go to that place in Burbank no
more Mor because they always put people
next to you bro the place is empty get
them out of here bro I don't want people
next to me you know at a movie theater
don't sitting next to me I don't give a
[__] what the best seats are there's a
seat everywhere get the [__] out of here
want nobody next to me Southwest you
come in the plane is empty you want to
sit here with food they came in with
look at us with coffees and food the
poor husband that
jerk and she's like walking around with
like a fake fur and I'm like you're not
sitting here you you're not sitting here
no I was coming back not sitting here I
refus to let you [__] sit I don't
want food in my [__] aisle call the
storter this besides there's open seats
yeah I don't want somebody in the
[__] middle bringing in that St and
she sat with somebody with two people in
the seat and I sat here with the whole
thing open and there was a bunch of
seats open if you're on Southwest and
you're sitting next to somebody and the
plane's empty you're a [__] [__]
get up I don't want nobody [__] next
to me no never never at a restaurant if
it's empty go go I don't want you know I
don't get that [__] thing I don't get
it I love kids but you know when you go
out if it's adults out and you're
sitting and like every time if the
you're like oh sweet it's empty we'll be
able to talk we can hang out breathe a
little bit a [__] kindergarten comes
in and they sit them right next to you
and they're going
bananas move other side you got why
would you do that I don't understand and
I've been in the restaurant industry
[__] eight nine years before I
started other [__] it's like you never
do that I don't understand the logic
behind
that togetherly no more Subway Jersey
mics okay it's good I like Jersey mik
Jersey miks and if you wor your diet you
get the regular turkey and provalone
with lettuce and tomato boom and they
got wheat bread and mayonnaise light
mayonnaise for you you like light
mayonnaise I'm not I don't like that
[__] I'm just saying for you I light
mayonnaise just in case okay you know
what I'm saying just in
case you take sandwiches really
seriously I take food really seriously
that's why I'm 300 lb not because I'm
[__] around or you know I will NE
like never like I just a couple months
ago D this is how crazy I am I had a
producer that wanted to meet
me and like okay what do you want to
meet he goes I'll call you when I get
lunch and we'll meet this guy made a
mistake he was a guy when he went to
that thae restaurant when he called me
and he goes I'm at the thae restaurant
come on over I go ah I don't do thae
brother he goes then come on in I go I
don't even sit at those [__] places
all right I'm not going in there I know
a TI chick she was filthy she had bugs
in the house listen I just don't want to
go in there he couldn't believe it he
couldn't like he called me went out to a
different place he took me to the Jew
place where they sell machine guns arom
Aroma On Sunset the best best the best
of Roma what you talking next time you
never taking her there right no why
would you why would you why why would
you why would
you why would you you get mad at me for
going to Hollywood why would you [__]
take it there
they got hummus and they got grape bread
and they got Jew food why would you take
it that tell me
why it's no pizza you better [__]
take it there before the next week okay
you better take I don't give a [__]
about Korea food we're going to Romas to
hang out with some juice I don't go to
Hollywood that often you going to start
[__] going but you'll go downtown
like a [__] half a Momo let me go
downtown you haven't taken it Roma
yet steak with the [__] steak french
fries if you've been through Aroma it's
good oh oh it's just a ton of food the
salmon salad for lunch they'll [__] you
up in there the [__] steak on steak
fries they have a caught up steak they
give you on steak fries they got this
grape bread they get from Israel with
butter on it that ahead's good God damn
they got all that Jew I've never been
there no because
yel let's see what yel say maybe they'll
take an
Uber maybe they have a deal with Uber we
could go on Uber and go to [__]
Yelp millions of people use Yelp and and
you're the only person who has a problem
with it Go Yelp and Uber cuz I go by
love I need some [__] stranger I'm
not going but how do you find places I
already I find them myself I don't need
some [__] dumb stranger that lives in
this area to tell me that I went to this
Chinese place it was Exquisite no it's
not East Coast so I was was it going to
[__] be they don't have an egg roll
where that's what I was going to say
where you go for your egg roll I had to
stop yeah I had to stop the green apple
that's yeah that's what I was going to
say yeah that's that's the closest not
that's an explosion they put a bunch of
[__] in the thing and explode you know
what I get when I go there what do you
get the French filet minion that's what
I get with the asparagus how delicious
is that that's not [__] around how
the [__] you go to
Chin I told you 20 times about that
place you didn't tell me the name of the
place Chinese it's green apple you know
because she found the place downtown
listen shut the [__] up I'm going to
drive downtown because you found the
place I found the [__] place too I'm
Ventura down the block from [__]
Jerry's okay I told you this three
months ago well we go to this place from
didn't you go tell them didn't you go to
Santa Monica for dumplings didn't you
because you found the place on you out
didn't you Santa Monica was a cooking
class you no no but then you went down
there for the [__] dumplings too one
time it wasn't that good would you do a
little Ser J yeah you could have gone
over here dog you could have gone right
here that's the best thing they got for
sure what's that the
fet doesn't matter it's so F doesn't
matter this food sucks if you're from
[__] the East Coast you can't fall
into this leag cannot fall into you
can't be taking rides around [__]
town you don't have that time we're
[__] professionals here you're coming
over I'm taking the studio we're going
back to the house you're putting the
bikini on and we're going to work what's
all this drama put the bikini on and
we're going to work dog going to work
I'm putting you to work what the [__]
you've been studying all week it's time
to work Jack everybody wants to [__]
die and go to heaven right or wrong you
told me yourself you want to have sex
why do you get involved when you're
sitting in Career Town eating aren't you
just staring at her
going I can't wait to [__] you but now
it's another hour before I get home on
the train right or wrong you just sit
there really enjoying yourself they're
good yeah like really enjoying yourself
when I take my wife on that the whole
time I'm looking at her like
I'm going to take you home and [__]
punch you and do everything to you you
dirty [__] you think I'm worried about
that's why I don't get myself involved
in that predicament of an hour and a
half meal that's why everything's
delivery everything's
delivery I going [__] downtown it's
Friday night it's dick
night going
downtown I haven't seen you a [__]
week you want to take another two hours
out of my life to go get [__]
dumplings really really really
Friday night is Dick night dick night at
the house and guess what Saturday night
is Dick night dick night
again after you dick then you go to The
Comedy Store later because you got your
dick in there it doesn't matter you want
to laugh laugh go ahead what do I
get then you take him back give another
stabing right or wrong what do you care
what do you care who gives a [__] dick
kn
I gotta do some shout outs here on
it optimization to the [__] Max you
understand me you want to be the best
you want to have dick Knight in your
house go to hit.com they have a
tremendous product called Alpha Brain
neut Tropics it'll [__] put you on a
different planet and here's the beauty
part it's a 100% moneyback guarantee you
don't like it you're seeing [__]
stars your dick don't get hard you call
on it you send send it back no questions
asked have to we'll send you a check you
don't have to send it back all right
that's a [__] 100% guarantee who does
that for you now does that dumpling
place [__] do that [__] sucker [__]
no go to honor.com and press in church
and get 10% off your first [__] order
and stay on it and you get another 10%
off and tell them my sent you get
another [__] 10% off but if you got
if you're a Jew you get 0% [__]
interest okay number two Iron Dragon TV
it's a real cool Channel it streams
tremendous classic martial art films
whether you're into the IT Man series
and new martial art F and new martial
art films and Mafia and they have on it
workout films they got a ton of stuff
and they growing daily every week day fo
he adds new [__] movies to that
they're also going to have the new 4K
technology this is tremendous
opportunity for you you looking at me
going but Joey I don't like Chinese
[__] food I don't give a [__] if you
don't like Chinese movies you're getting
two free [__] movies for free right
yeah put your name what did it press in
the Box Joey Joey you get two [__]
free Chinese movies when was the last
time you watch a Chinese [__] movie
that's right go to Iron Dragon TV right
[__]
now look at what they got look at the
web page guarantee you're GNA love it
okay they got Jackie Chan they got who's
the other got Sunny [__] cha they're
not [__] around go to Iron Dragon TV
right now and press in Joey and get two
free films two free rentals absolutely
free on Uncle Joey you're sitting there
going to myself my balls ditch you know
why your balls ditch cuz you're
underwear [__] disgusting you've had
them on for a day and a half you got pee
in them you got [__] stains in them it
looks like somebody shot a musket in
them they're disgusting those white
[__] things not to mention it's 2015
I got the solution me on the [__]
underwear even they even make me look
[__] sexy my flat [__] ass was
banging those [__] things it cups
your nut sack I got a pair on right now
they feel [__] tremendous if I start
you could sniff my hand right now and
then I'll stick it in my thing juggle my
nuts pull it out and let you sniff it
again there's no difference you
understand me because the material it
keeps the sweat I don't know what it
does it just [__] pulls the sweat
from the nut sack and your nut sack what
you're saying is Advanced nut sack
technology technology no stink nut sack
when I had the surgery don't say a
[__] word Chinese dumpling man
[__] God knows what your undies
look like I have good undies yeah I know
[__] white cotton things with streaks
and [__] what color on these you got
black you better wear black you [__] I
forget what color you got sperm in there
and little [__] you have sperm on
your helmet in the little cup what you
think going to leave the house and sperm
on my dick go to me.com right now press
in Joey Joey in the box and get 20% off
your first order and the deliver for
free anywhere in Canada and the US and
the US that's meundies right now go to
meundies look at their catalog they got
girl underwear they got boy undies don't
say that no more people got
mad you know they got they got nice look
cuz last week you said they got boy
underwear or I don't [__] know man so
so [__] some gay guy [__] hit me
up and said Lee wants to suck my dick
but he doesn't want no dumpling nuts I
don't [__] know anyway compated go to
me.com right now look at the great
selection of men and women underwear
they have and go crazy it's a tremendous
product it fits great it feels great
they're comfortable I feel like I'm
[__] floating go to me on these right
now and receive 20% off your first Total
and free [__] delivery who does
that for you
you're sitting there going boy I'm
getting fat boy this resolution ain't
working but at the same time you're
eating some [__] shitty potato chips
that [__] stops right now you know why
cuz Uncle Joey's coming in strong for
the [__] New Year by now you've
already tapped on your resolution I
don't give a [__] you know why cuz I got
the best thing going
naturebox.com the delicious nutritious
snacks sent directly to your house just
like meundies just like [__] an I
don't [__] around I send [__] right to
your [__] house you don't need to go
downtown you need to get on the [__]
train nothing you just [__] go to
naturebox.com press get five different
[__] snacks and guess what they're
free the first time four mediumsized bag
one big siiz bag I'm telling you from
the [__] cocoa almonds to the to the
to the s to the Sriracha cews which
everybody's [__] eating now those
things are delicious to the [__] uh
Kettle kernels Kettle kernels to the
Sweet and Sour Whatever a [__] uh
what's the trail mix they have a a trail
mix that is so [__] delicious with
big pieces of chocolate kisses in it all
that [__] right now listen I could talk
about this [__] for hours who needs the
aggravation you're probably a little
stoned you want to go to bed you want to
whack off go to naturebox.com press in
Joey and get 20 how much no free bucks
free free who's better than me I give
you free 20% off two free movies and 10%
off vitamins you don't get that nowhere
please go to Nature Box and support them
it's a free [__] box you're wasting
your [__] time listening to this
podcast if you don't get those [__]
nature box go to meundies get some
underwear go to Iron Dragon TV it's the
best thing you've ever done and on
it.com tremendous optimization Mick yeah
MCB Court from the MCB Court podcast how
many shows you do a week one just one
everyone drops
Monday new episode every Monday we're on
episode 83 84 drops next week Bo got to
pissed me off what happened huh with
that Subway sandwich why you got to get
me stuff still I'm sorry I apologize for
my lunch choice no more Subway you got a
foot long didn't you hell yeah wait till
that piece of [__] comes out of your
ass what's it going to smell like death
just take it out and look at it it don't
even look like real [__] it looks like
turkey [__] that's what probably even
the [__] isn't real no it's turkey [__]
that's that's you lucky I love you what
do you got pln so when are you leaving
Thursday night Thursday night when are
you come back Sunday afternoon look at
you 3-day weekend everybody's rocking
down there yeah it's her birthday I
could just imagine she probably wants to
eat here wants to eat there what
happened there's no hotels in North
Hollywood this [__] weekend why would
I take her to North Hollywood because
it's a beautiful Town that's why you get
a review she you can see the mountain
that [__] holiday and 200 a night and
like the car dealership what you what
are you doing let me know what's the
week entail let me let me she has a
couple taco places we're going to go to
Steve's friend by The Comedy Store okay
what else I know there's a by the way no
that's a bunch of just cool restaurants
cool restaurant I don't know she went
there for college he likes it down
there you ate the [__] Crepes just so
everyone knows he makes fun of me for
crepe class but you ate did you have you
made Crepes since then no then what was
the [__] use again you want to
[__] you went to the other [__] the
macaroon class how many macaroons have
you made since then none okay and know
what's the other class you went to just
crepe okay okay so it's a waste of
[__] time cuz ain't nobody going to
cook you don't [__] cook on the
weekend all did you go to a macaroon
class at 8 morning a crepe class you
wouldn't go to Ruth Chris to get free
steak can you imagine this this what I'm
talking about and he went to the
macaroon class at 8 in the morning not 8
in the morning you do you I mean cuz you
can share Gmail calendars did she give
you an opportunity to schedule time to
see your
balls that's on the that's on the agenda
do you get to that is insane though that
you would do that you're that you're
that caring yet you wouldn't go I mean
let do you not like steak I love steak
I've been I've been I've gotten steak
with him a few times I don't understand
I don't understand but they they sent us
in a very nice gift I didn't want to
waste if she didn't like it she gets her
Stakes well done why am I going to go to
that you the [__] what she gets she that
night you she wasn't getting dick she
was going to sit that's a no dick night
she was going to sit there and watch you
eat a s that's where you maybe if she
was good you let her smell
it in your meundies you imagine that two
times I called him dog come over no we
want pizza we got on a diet and piz now
again if it was pizza sent out from New
York I could see it oh [__] Le you
getting some pizza in it's a special
occasion [__] vomit he got from
Laurel Canyon that he that wasn't vomit
he made me go get it I did I mean you
asked me where it was and I told you
it's good pizza it was great pizza is it
as good as a pizza in your neighborhood
oh how would I know you go to [__]
Little Caesar in I don't go to they
didn't have Little Caesars in Boston
what they have what did you get tell me
you went to next Pizza no you didn't I
went to sbur Pizza the town where I grew
up cbury is it good did you take Paul
day no I we didn't go it was snowing
when I was back there why wouldn't you
take Paul it's a 45 minute drive in the
snow your whole [__] town yeah but my
mom lives near Boston now she moved out
okay from just and did they have any
pizza in Boston you took it to yeah
what's which one we are we my favorite
place in Boston a arnestos cuz I lived
in in the North End the Italian section
it's a small place they do the the big
slices you like they just put in for
like 2 minutes let it heat up it's great
did you take her there no we didn't go
we didn't we were there for like 4 days
that's the pizza you take it to and then
when you bring her here you go we ain't
eating this [__] out here no more that's
the pizza you should have taken to
anestos and go this is pizza so don't
ever ask again like if it's not arnestos
I'm not [__] eating it I'm a o co guy
I'm to the Bone here no California
Kitchen no nothing when you go to
[__] nestos you're going to look me
in the face and tell me that lurel
Canyon is as good as Ernesto no what is
it compared to nestos tell me the truth
if her nestos is a 10 what is that
Laurel Canyon Place six and a half seven
four no not a four a four no more pizza
le that's you've never been to I don't
need to [__] go you're just making
them numbers that make your AR even work
we all having an nestos and every
neighborhood and nothing that you're
ever going to eat is going to match up
to
that so I can't give I'm not going to
have pizza for the rest of my
life it's not going to never the only
place I eat pizza is at that mall that
[__] Joe's pizza from New York oh
yeah yeah Sant Monica right no right up
here but they just built one that's the
same guy that started in Santa Monica
that's good that's where you [__] go
for a slice where Joe's the Joe's not
Joe peeps Joe's no Joe peeps is [__]
puke too yeah Joe's oh my God I was
hungry and I was in acupuncture when I
went to Joe peeps I [__] [__] in the
backyard I mean it went right through
the sauce went right from my mouth right
to my ass like I threw away both slices
yeah that's how bad Joe peeps was I
threw away both [__] slices like they
used artificial cheese I could tell
cheap cheese that's what they don't know
out here that's the difference is that
[__] cheese is [__] up and the
water's [__] up the cheese is [__]
the is does water make that big of a
difference cuz you always see bring New
York water for bagels and stuff but that
lasts for a week and then they've
realized they have people who buy Bagels
at a store from the east coast and they
go why am I doing this that's why all
those PE when I first moved here the
pizza was in Rondo Beach next to the
comedy magic club that was the end all B
that was the word they have gallons of
water from Jersey but then I was talking
to the guy when he goes for what these
[__]
Gentiles will eat [__] Dominos
they're from the East Coast because it's
99 a [__] Pizza you know no this is
what you get if you're from there I went
to Long Island one time on the elevator
there was a kid with a Domino's thing I
had to control myself beating this
[__] kid just swinging at him and his
parents for being so [__] stupid and
[__] ignorant you understand me what
about the guy D Mingo who got like a
turkey sandwich oh I was going to beat
him too a white dude with slippers on he
got a [__] turkey on white you could
have done this at Subway or [__]
Ralphs B's head please no he didn't even
get B's head I don't want to pay the
extra premium I want the regular tet
listen get the [__] out out of here go
to [__] Subway eat that [__] I love
you [__] Buffalo helium see you
this weekend Columbus see you the
following week we'll be back Monday with
a new Fantastic podcast we're doing
mushrooms on Monday we're getting [__]
up with my man lee it's over we're doing
mushrooms on Monday [__] yeah thank you
Mick for coming on I love you please
support M MCB Court follow him on
Twitter what is it MCB court and follow
him go to his shows he's a solid dude I
love him he's like my brother so you you
were just on MCB Court that's right yeah
yeah a couple episodes go thank you
thank you all right this show is
sponsored by NatureBox uh don't forget
to go to naturebox.com and sign out to
get your free no more Subway only nature
boox get your free Nature Box sampler
box of great tasting healthy snacks
forget the vending machine and Subway
and start snacking Smarter with
delicious treats like barbecue Kettle
Kettle kernels go to naturebox.com Joey
that's naturebox.com Joey for men's and
women's underwear go to meundies.com
Joey
and get 20% off of your first order and
free shipping in the United States and
Canada go to on it.com and use C- Word
Church to get 10% off of all their
optimization products like Alpha Brandon
new mood and go to irondragon tv.com
news C- Joey to get two free rentals of
all of their great martial arts
movies